So, for someone who's new to the profession,
I think the best thing to do is
start new projects and do things that you enjoy doing, because if you're doing something you enjoy doing,
you're gonna have such a better learning experience by doing that.
Look for mentorship.
Sometimes you just need to ask, and you will be surprised how many people are willing to help with that.
Learn the basics, like learn the JavaScript, learn the CSS, learn the HTML.
Yeah, I kind of agree,
Like, I went through so long and I didn't know HTTP, and that messed up so much of my understanding,
but I still think if I stopped and tried to learn HTTP that early on,
I would have just abandoned the whole thing, because I wouldn't have…
I mean
you also have to be realistic, like many people start with a job, and in that job,
we use frameworks, you probably don't have the time to learn the basics.
So I'm not saying, like, you're doing it wrong if you not learn the basics first,
It's just that I recommend, I think it's time well invested.
I recommend speaking at conferences, like, before you even get a job in tech, speak at a conference, just make it up,
because it's really good for your profile, right?
That's how you get it up in the first place!
Exactly!
Fake it 'till you make it.
Fake it 'till you make it!
This is my first time in JSConf Budapest, it's amazing.
I love the diversity over here.
As an experience wise, it's amazing and the things I'm learning here is also very great, because, though I'm an infra engineer,
there are certain concepts which are relevant to a DevOps engineer as well,
like how you should communicate to your architects,
how you should work in collaboration with your product manager and the way you build your products.
Maybe we can also think of having accessibility in DevOps, whatever products we're building,
So yeah, it's quite relevant.
JSConf Budapest is my first conference as an attendee, and my very first conference as a speaker,
it's all new to me, and I had a wonderful time. Thank you all so much!
My experience of JSConf has been really good so far, we've been able to travel here with the whole family,
got a lovely family room at the hotel,
the food has been good and all of the communications and the help I've gotten as a speaker has been, blew my mind.
For me a very humbling experience to be here today
This is one of the places where the people are so nice and so open. I love the community here
Last time I was at JSConf Budapest, I got hit in the eye by an HDMI dongle.
What a great memory!
Yeah.
I think my favorite memory is my very first talk as a Googler with JSConf EU 2015.
It was a bad talk but it was a great community.
I wasn't there.
No, you weren't.
It's my first time in any JSConf conferences and it's been amazing, I don't know, it's amazing content all the time.
It goes outside of what you would expect from a tech conference.
My favorite talk so far has been the talk of this guy that works with refugee aid camp,
which is something we would never have access to this, like, anywhere else, and I think, like, that,
alongside with the community here that seems to be very friendly and very respectful, I'm having a blast, like I'm having the best time.
My favorite JSConf memory was talking to the organizer of JSConf EU,
and kind of hearing his authentic heart for the conference
and how he wants to get everybody involved irrespective of race and gender and orientation, just,
it's a conference for everybody.
When I think of JSConf, I think inclusion, family, community.
So none of those are technical.